توجهت الرئيسه توت تايوان في رحله الى
امريكا اللاتينيه تتوقف فيها في الولايات
المتحده في طريق
ذهابها وايابها هذا التوقف في الاراضي
الامريكيه لرئيسه تايوان التي تعتبرها
الصين جزءا من اراضيها استدعى رد فعل صيني
يحذر من ان هذا الامر يعد استزاز ويحث
واشنطن على عدم السماح بحصول ذلك وقال
المكتب الحكومي الصيني لشؤون تايوان ان
هذا الامر يلحق الضرر بسياده الصين ووحده
اراضيها ويقوض السلامه والاستقرار في مضيق
تايوان وحذر من ان الصين ستتخذ بالتاكيد
اجراءات للرد بشكل حازم وحثى واشنطن على
عدم اجراء اي اتصال
برئيسه تايوان
دورها عربه المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الصينيه ماونينج عن معارضه بلادها الشديده
لاي شكل من اشكال التبادلات الرسميه بين
الولايات المتحده وتايوان مؤكده انبيجين
ترفض زياره الرئيس التايوانيه
للولايات المتحده تحت اي ظرف على حد قولها
نعرض بشده اي شكل من اشكال الاتصال الرسمي
بين الولايات المتحده والتايوان كما نعرض
بشده زياره مسؤولين التايوانيين الى
الولايات المتحده تحت اي ظرف او سبب نعرض
بشده انتهاك الولايات المتحده لمبدا الصين
واحده الصين قدمت احتجاجات رسميه للجانب
الامريكي في مناسبات عده بشان زياره
المتحده
وبينما قال مصور الامريكي الى الرئيس جوبا
ايضا قال انه سيجري اتصالا قريبا على طريق
الصيني حذرت الولايات المتحده اصيله من اي
رد فعل مبالغ فيه وقال مسؤول كبير في
الاداره الامريكيه انه لا يوجد اي سبب على
الاطلاق يجعل صينه تستخدم ذلك ذريعه لرد
فعل مبالغ فيه او لممارسه مزيدا من الضغط
على تايوان
تواصل تبادل وجهات النظر مع بيجين حول
مجموعه واسعه من القضايا عبر قنوات
دبلوماسيه متعدده ورفض المسؤول تاكيد
احتمال انعقاد اجتماع في كاليفورنيا
والزعيم الجمهوري في مجلس النواب كيفن
ماكارسي
المتحذر من هذه الولايه بينما حسب مسؤول
اخر بيجين على ابقاء قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه
مع واشنطن
من بيجين تنضم الينا مراسله الجزيره شيماء
جويييل لنفهم اكثر شيماء لماذا جاء الرد
في فعل الصيني على هذا النحو
نعم عبد الصمد وسلمى هو موقف معارض شديد
اللهجه من الجانب الصيني سواء على مستوى
وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه التي تابعنا قبل
قليل مؤتمر صحفيا لها او من خلال تصريحات
صباح اليوم صدرت عن المتحدثه باسم المكتب
مكتب الشؤون التايوانيه التابعه لمجلس
الدوله الصيني هو موقف الحقيقه عبد الصمد
لو نظرنا الى تاريخ زيارات الرئيس
التايواني الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لا يخرج عن سياقات المواقف الصينيه
السابقه تجاه زياراتها السابقه تجدر
الاشاره الى ان الزياره السابعه منذ
تقلدها منصبها رئيسه لتايوان منذ عام 2016
هي الزياره السابعه لها للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه خلال الزيارات السته السابقه
الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ايضا كانت
ردود الفعل من الجانب الصيني رسميا كانت
شديده اللهجه وايضا قد نشهد خلال الايام
المقبله عبد الصمد ليس فقط ردودا سياسيه
او على المستوى الدبلوماسي والسياسي من
الجانب
ربما نشهد ايضا ردودا على المستوى العسكري
خاصه وان الصين ومن خلال المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الصينيه قالت بانها سوف تراقب
الوضع بان الجانب الصيني سوف يراقب الوضع
خلال الايام المقبله وذلك خلال الزياره
التي ستمتد بالنسبه للرئيسه
الايام المقبله حتى السابع من الشهر
المقبل في جوله طويله في دول منطقه امريكا
الوسطى تستهلها بجواتيمالا ومن المتوقع
ايضا ان تتوقف خلال عودتها ايضا الى
تايوان على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بحسب الاجنده والمعلومات المتوفره لزياره
سئيم فان هنالك مقابلات واجتماعات سوف
تجريها مع عدد من المسؤولين الامريكيين في
اداره بيض وهذا ما يثير حفيظه الصين خاصه
الزياره المتوقعه لها
كبن مكار في رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
وايضا عدد من المسؤولين الاخرين في
الاداره الامريكيه الصين صباح اليوم خلال
تصريحات المتحدثه باسم مكتب شؤون تايوان
لدى مجلس الدوله الصيني الجانب الامريكي
من التمادي في تنسيق ايه اجتماعات ثنائيه
سوف تجمع بين تاييمه خلال توقفها
بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه مع اي
مسؤولين اخرين ووصفت الخطوه الامريكيه
بتنسيق هذه الاجتماعات بان خطوه استفزازيه
من واشنطن تحديدا لبيجين وذلك لدعم الجانب
التايواني هنالك تحذير ايضا اليوم من قبل
وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه قبل قليل خلال
مؤتمر صحفي بان ايضا سوف تتخذ كافه
الاجراءات اللازمه لحمايه ما وصفته الامن
القومي للصين او الامن الوطني بالاراضي
الصينيه تايوان بطبيعه الحال عبد الصمد
بالنسبه لبيجين هي جزء لا يتجزا من
الاراضي الصينيه وهذا ما تطلق عليه الصين
مبدا الصين واحده وقد حثت ايضا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه على احترام مبدا الصين
واحده هذا المبدا الذي قامت عليه العلاقات
الدبل وماسيه بين بيجين وواشنطن منذ
انشائها في سبعينيات القرن الماضي اذا
يمكن القول ربما خلال الايام المقبله الى
حدود انتهاء زياره او جوله سيئين في دول
منطقه امريكا الوسطى حتى السابع من الشهر
المقبل ربما يكون هنالك تصعيد الى جانب
مواقف اكثر حده من الجانب الصناعي للايام
المقبله اشكرك في مراسله الجزيره من بيجي
شكرا لك